things like that so i definitely hope
uh we could get to see more of her
yeah
paula how are you today good how are you
i'm doing fantastic i absolutely
loved shanghai
you are fantastic
you you've accomplished a lot you're
you're a mother you're an award-winning
actress excuse me you
you've been an hbo series with nicole
kidman and now you're making your
big american debut in shanghai the
legend of tim rings but you know this is
a pretty historic movie so i'm curious
as to how you felt after the very first
time watching it
oh my god i was so emotional um i was
especially i surprised myself i was
especially emotional watching
simu uh simu and mangar singh with uh
tony so like the father and and and and
kids because i i wasn't there when they
filmed it and um watching it for the
first time
and then just you know kind of um
embodying like the you know the mother
role and seeing like you know i i cried
and i was like oh those were my babies
oh no don't fight with your dad and i
would say so emotional um i cried um
yeah but overall the you know the story
it's you know i never got to watch it
like adopt for a lot of things but i
just you know saw tiny bits of it but
you see it
see the foam in its entirety um it's so
magnificent it's so much bigger than i
imagined with you know all you know what
marvel does best
you know all the special effects you
know
like it was just so amazing to watch i
and i i feel like i still i haven't
having watched it for a few times i feel
like there's still a lot of things i i
didn't see and like i need to go watch
again
i've seen it twice uh i was at the
premiere then i saw the screening and i
was just as taken back
the second time is the first time truly
it's amazing each time i saw it but
speaking of finding those little things
each time you know your character seems
like
we learned about her but it still seems
like there's a bit of mystery
surrounding her her past her history you
know with her city and her people
speaking to destin the other day and he
you know he mentioned the sequel
and i was just curious if
this sequel happens would you like to
come back for it and if so what story
would you like to see your character
kind of go through and explain
of course i would love to come back to
it not only because you know
the story itself or the you know my love
with the character but like i became
fast friends with everybody especially
simu and monger we became
best buddies and we hang out all the
time i would love to work with them
again um and um but i think you know i i
would never know i probably would be the
last person to know where my character
will fall into
that you know that that that story but i
know that you know there's so much to
learn about
tallow the village and you know
why you know lee left a village and you
know how how did she why she planned for
you know she prepared the suits for her
kids you know when they become adults
you know seems like you know i think
also her strength or her confidence
comes from
her knowing you know a lot of things and
knowing herself
very well and i think that's the
contrast of you know with her the
father's you know his frustration of you
know what he wants out of his power and
his life but versus where i feel like
lee knows exactly what she can do with
her power and and and you know and and
what to do in you know moment of moments
of crisis and and things like that so i
definitely hope
um we could get to see more of her
yeah
yeah
like you said she she's such a powerful
character the the scene with win-win the
beginning it's a beautiful scene
thank you it's also really great to see
you're welcome man it really is
beautiful and it's actually funny uh not
funny but great i love how
the movie kind of revolves around you
everyone's love for you
it's pretty great i really really love
that was there any scene in particularly
especially with tony and leon that you
found challenging to film or were you
nervous about any scene in particular
um i was nervous any time tony was there
but then like that that that that
nervousness um kind of like just
subsided like five minutes in uh because
he's so easy to work with and he's just
so gentle and kind
humble um but um i think the most
challenging scene definitely was the
long the big fight scene um that you see
in the the green bamboo bamboo forest
just because there's just so much going
on
um with you know the very precise
movement
you know we're like flying around and
sometimes it's just like you know we
know exactly destin knows exactly what
shot he wants how close the framing and
everything so we have to be very precise
by making it look like it's so easy you
know and it's so beautiful and to tell
the story and i think my job foremost
is
the actor and you know i have to tell
the story um
and so you know to track the progression
of how they fall in love and then the
kind of like the you know them sizing
each other out and you know like so
all of that was it was just a lot to do
at the same time being like looking
straight into the eyes we knew like by
tony
and just like to calm that nervousness
and then like my heart was racing you
know
to do everything at the same time it was
a lot but i'm so glad it came out as
beautiful as it is
absolutely beautiful it's one of my
favorite scenes of the movie oh thank
you i wish we had more time to talk but
me too
thank you
bye